ten days ago I got a present through the
post this you can see it's a piece of
plastic and on it I written the letters
iyc 2011 that's for International Year
of chemistry 2011 what makes it special
was I was sent this by one of our
viewers
andrás Tretyakov who works in london and
he's a technician in the school
chemistry lab and he made this as an
experiment for making a much bigger sign
for his school the iyc is the
International Year of chemistry that is
celebrating the centenary of Madame
Curie's Nobel Prize in Chemistry in 1911
for the discovery of radium and polonium
so Andres and his colleagues at some
bull school in London was celebrating
the International Year of chemistry and
he's made a whacking big sign to go up
in the somewhere in the school and
what's special about his sign if you
look at it is that some of the letters
and numbers are purple and some are a
sort of yellowish grey color so he's
made this out of nanoparticles very
small particles of metal which have been
mixed with a plastic dissolved up in
some solvent and then put in these
spaces between these black lines that
he's drawn with some sort of plastic pen
and the solvent is evaporated in you're
left with plastic with these small
particles of metal embedded rather like
cherries in a cake and what is special
about this is that the metal particles
these purple ones are made of gold and
the yellowish ones are silver now you
will know what gold looks like like
wedding rings and so on so nice gold
color so why should it be purple and the
reason it's purple is that if you take a
small lump of metal atoms as you make it
smaller and smaller the color produced
by the metal atoms or the color of light
that it absorbs changes so a large lump
of gold looks like gold and as you make
it smaller you can change the color red
or even purple because the energy of the
electrons within this cluster of atoms
changes so he's chosen the sides I'm not
sure what size which gives this nice
purple color it's probably quite small
maybe a nanometer ten to the minus nine
meters might be slightly more but it's
really quite small a few tens of
thousands of atoms or less and the
silver is probably a similar sort of
size I know because my research group
has made nanoparticles of silver can't
afford gold we've made nanoparticles of
silver and sort of seven to ten
nanometers diameter give this sort of
color I like this because first of all
it's celebrating the year of chemistry
and secondly because it's really nice
chemical demonstration in its own right
what are you gonna do with it I haven't
decided entirely but I think that I'm
going to hang it up like this so that
when people come into my office they can
see that it's international year of
chemistry